منور اللي همم الاخبار العاجله تظهر على
الشاشه التلفزيون
اغلبيه الاصوات التي تمكينها من نيلي ثقه
لكنست اذا هذا هو الخبر العاجل الوارد على
شاشه الجزيره وكنا نتابع طوال اليوم وهذه
الصور ايضا تاتينا من الكنيسه الاسرائيلي
حيث كان يتم التصويت على منح الثقه لحكومه
تتنياهو الجديده وهي سادس حكومه نتنياهو
الحكومه الجديده
باغلبيه 64 من الاصوات وهذه صور كما ذكرنا
تاتينا من الكنيسه الاسرائيلي الذي كانت
هذا اليوم يبحث ويناقش منح الثقه لحكومه
التي وصفت بانها الاسد تطرفا ضمن همم
اتفاق مع احزاب يمينيه يقودها سومتريش
وايضا بين كبير وكان هناك انتقادات كبيره
اللي نتنياهو لاتخاذ هذا النهج
بائتلاف حكومي تدخل فيه احزاب وصفت بانها
متطرفه
من القوانين التي تم تعديلها ما يتعلق
بانتخاب نواب وزراء حتى لو كان عليهم
احكام جنائيه تم تعديل هذا القانون وحدد
نتنياه الخطوط العريضه لحكومته وقال ان من
اولويه اولوياته هو توسيع الاستيطان في
المختلف المناطق